and the nazis that are dark magga and
you know
it's not surprising that these people
are saying the quiet part out loud
it really isn't um amanda points out
something here she says trump doesn't
care if they're qualified he's a fascist
loyalty is the only qualification
and you're right amanda you're right
because that's what fascists want they
want loyalty to their regime
speaking of loyalty to their regime
i don't know if you guys have seen uh or
heard of jd vance jd vance is the guy
who made him who wrote a book and made a
movie about
uh country people becoming elites and
leaving behind their country
and their their country roots their
redneck roots and becoming elites now
he's a he's a traitor to
his uh his culture i guess you would say
but jd vance loves hitler he's in love
with hitler america's hitler that is
and jd vance has been
been discovered that he text his
roommate
in 2016 when donald trump was running he
called donald trump at the time
america's hitler
jd vance the guy running for senate in
ohio
who just received america's hitler's
endorsement
and this is how hitler works i think
this is how it works folks
like
jd vance
isn't wrong about america's hitler
trump that is being america's hitler not
wrong
and it is evident in jd vance himself
like he proves it outright
that the fascist regime
the fascist that is donald trump
america's hitler that is donald trump
even though he's a nin kapoor nazi
because let's face it he is a ninja boop
nazi
the whole point is is that when you need
to
get power yourself or maintain your own
power
you will capitulate to the regime
you will capitulate to
fascism so yeah jd
he is america's hitler now listen to
what jd said
on steve bannon's traitor tv st speaking
of [ __ ] dark manga and nazis
jd vance appears on steve bannon's
trader tv here
but listen to the sound
of jd vance
how much he loves america's hitler let's
listen
make the cage right now get a couple of
minutes make the case to make trump to
say this is my guy because i agree with
trump he's certainly the best president
of my lifetime he was a fighter for
people that i care about more than any
politician in the in in this country in
in 30 40 years i'm on the team as the
president said jd gets it i'm actually
going to stand for the president
so basically jd vance is saying i love
the president i love trump trump's my
guy and trump loves me because i love
him it's exactly what ma amanda is
saying
is that it has nothing to do with
qualifications jd vance may not even be
qualified to be dog catcher but he
definitely is loyal to america's hitler
and the reason why is because jd vance
loves fascism that's the secret here
folks
trump is not the [ __ ] problem trump
is the symptom
dark manga
fascism in our country people
people
greedy for for american authoritarianism
that's the problem folks
that's the problem
it's american this this longing for
american authoritarianism
that is our problem trump is just the
symptom
trump is just the symptom hell hitler
was a symptom in nazi germany
the disease
the disease was their longing for
authoritarianism for someone to wave a
magic wand and to fix all their problems
and that's just not the way it works in
society
not everyone's problems are fixed with
one swing of the wand
now jd vance believes that because jd
vance believes he's an elite
and elites typically believe
that when the magic wand is waived it is
waved in their favor
just like steve bannon and donald trump
and all the other sycophants
that have continued on this scourge for
authoritarianism
so jd vance suckles at the teat
of america's hitler
and this is dark manga this is it right
in front of you and the reason why it's
dark maga is because jd vance
is the dog and dark magga is the tail
and the tail is wagging the dog
jd vance is not capitulating to donald
trump because he thinks hitler good
he doesn't care if hitler's good or not
he doesn't care if hitler's good for you
or not he doesn't care if there's
equality he doesn't care if there's
equity he's a rich white elite
he made it he made it out of being a
redneck
he made it he's now an elite he ain't
got to worry about all that [ __ ]
mj said he's got eyeliner on he probably
has to worry about his eyeliner he might
have to
i don't know you know i i maybe he's
wearing makeup maybe he's not and maybe
that's you know maybe what he's showing
off for trump here is
um his makeup skills i mean trump
requires makeup skills that's why i
never figured out why trump likes bannon
jesus christ this guy [ __ ]
you couldn't put enough makeup on this
[ __ ]
but dark manga
the alt-right
the fascists in this country the white
supremacists the nazis
the nazis in this country
are the tail that are wagging the dog
and they want authoritarianism they want
it bad
because they know what authoritarian
brings
authoritarianism brings them the ability
to take away consent from you
about your children
take away your consent they know what it
will do is give them the ability to tear
down the public education system
so that way they can indoctrinate
children into their way of being and
they can also marry them that's what
they want to do they want to marry
children they don't want children to be
educated enough not to know not to marry
them i mean what i mean by that is old
white men want to marry little girls
they also don't want you to be smart
enough to know about equality and equity
or have the brains enough to know
that
gender is not sexualized they don't want
you to know that gender has nothing to
do with sexuality they don't want you to
know that
they don't even want you to do math in
florida they're like math [ __ ] math
we're banning all math books [ __ ] math
we're not doing that
we're for division just not long
division
that's dark maga
that's where we're at folks and it's
going to continue
it's going to continue it's not going to
stop it's not like dark maga is the last
stop in american authoritarianism
it's not
it's not the last stop
they're gonna re-brand dark manga is the
alt-right the the [ __ ] tiki torch
[ __ ] that showed up at
charlottesville that's dark maga
that's dark manga it's the same
[ __ ]
it it ain't like people woke up this
morning and decided well we're dark
manga now instead of the alt-right we're
not trump supporters anymore we're dark
manga
and they're looking for revenge and the
revenge they're looking for is to
revenge on our democracy because they
really are pissed off that they weren't
able to tear down our democracy on
january 6. they're really [ __ ] pissed
about it they weren't able to overthrow
our constitution they're so upset about
it that they're still
still trying to overturn elections
inside of states our vote
trying to overturn and overthrow our
vote it's ours not theirs
joe biden is not
is not the united states president he's
our president
we elected him just like we elected
barack obama we elected donald trump we
elected george w bush as much as people
don't like it we did that and we did it
under our election system
the same same way we've been doing it
for for several several decades
under our election system
with the primary process
the general election process and we have
an election coming up
the 2022 midterms and it's up to us the
pro-democracy people to make sure that
american
authoritarianism does not take control
in this country and i'm not just talking
about in the united states house of
congress
i'm talking about in the senate i'm
talking about in the state governorships
i'm talking about in the state
legislators your county commissions
your city councils your school boards
this is all important the dark maga the
alt-right the nincapoop nazis
as they are do not take over control
and do not push american
authoritarianism we can not let
authoritarianism
take hold in this country
we must
not
let
authoritarianism take control of our
country and the way we do that is to be
pro-democracy all the time everywhere
all the time everywhere we have to have
strategic outrage we have to have our
messaging together
that's important and they're giving us
all the messaging we need because folks
the generic ballot
the people out there who don't pay
attention to politics but are going to
go vote against something we have to
give them something to vote against
we must
our messaging is important
we can't just say go vote because
democrats want to give you this
democrats want to give you that
look republicans the change that is
coming with republicans
you can see it all around you
they want to ban math books they want to
marry your children they want to take
women's bodily autonomy away
so much so that they don't have liberty
the women's vote is next hec they're
trying to stop black people from voting
they're stopping they're stopping
groceries from coming into our country
to damage joe biden in the next election
greg abbott is stopping groceries from
coming in our country think about that
for a second
you don't think that's a good way for
texas
that you want that's the change
that texas wants is to make sure that
groceries get on their shelves because
we literally have empty shelves abbott
down in texas trying to stop groceries
from coming in our country
yes he turned his policy around
but
the [ __ ] republican
in tennessee turned their policy around
after they told us yeah i want to marry
a 14 year old girl
that's what they said
by not having an age limit in their law
they're trying to use discrimination
against lgbtq community
to pass a law to where they can marry
children and they're like oh wait you
caught us being pedophiles well we're
not pedophiles
yes you are
greg abbott's like oh you caught me
you know
stopping groceries at the border
groceries that texas
definitely need to eat
and for grocery store shelves to be full
and he tuck tailed and run no
he still owns that just because a
republican decides not to do something
doesn't mean they won't do it again you
think greg abbott
won't try to won't try to hurt texans
because he thinks it's politically good
for him
come on now he's gonna do it over and
over he did it with the power grid he
did it with groceries
you don't think that republicans these
pedocons all around the country who are
who are trying to sexualize your kid's
gender and who are trying to marry your
[ __ ] children
trying to take away a age limit on
marrying children
you think they're just going to stop
wanting to marry children just because
they took it out of this bill
what about the next bill that's all
they're [ __ ] focused on they can't
focus on anything else but taking
people's liberty away from them and you
don't think they'll come for you
these are the people you want in charge
of your economy these are the people you
want in charge of your children's
education the ones who want to marry
your kids
you want to rely on these people
to be in charge of your gas prices
the people who are who are making sure
to stop groceries from being on the
grocery store shelves that's who you
want in charge of gas prices
the republicans the kid diddlers the
petal cons the gqp dark maga the ninka
poop nazis
that's who you want in charge of our
economy that's who you want in charge of
our children's education
that's who you want in charge of our
health care
those folks
that's the messaging